Yes. My question is on Alzheimer's. Why
is it more prevalent today that than it
was 15 20 years ago?
Well, actually Alzheimer's disease was a
disease that did not exist 40 years ago.
Uh Alzheimer's disease even by another
name could not be found in any medical
dictionary or textbook or taught in any
medical curriculum. It only became an
entity in the medical literature in
1979. And today it's apparently the
number four killer of adults in the
United States over the age of 65 behind
cardiovascular disease, cancer,
diabetes, and then comes Alzheimer's
disease. And it's appears uh to me with
no doubt that it's due to what I call a
physician cause disease because doctors
have have encouraged people in fact
demanded that people give up saturated
fat and cholesterol and move towards a
cholesterol restricted or even a
cholesterol-free diet to get their blood
cholesterol down below 200. And they
have created no less than 25 of these
cholesterol deficiency diseases. And to
me Alzheimer's disease is one of the big
ones. 75% of our brain weight is pure
cholesterol. It's called myelin. It's
this fatty stuff that insulates each
nerve fiber, the brain and spinal cord.
And we can only make about 10% of our
daily need of cholesterol. The other 90%
must come from the diet. And if a person
is very very good at giving up chicken
skin and red meat and dairy and eggs
like a doctor would have them do, after
about six or eight or 10 years, they're
not going to be able to keep up with the
maintenance and repair needs of the
cholesterol for the myelin and the brain
and spinal cord. And so you can just
expect that the person is going to
develop one or more of these 25
physician caused diseases including
acquired seizure disorders and
Alzheimer's disease. Now the best way to
avoid Alzheimer's disease is to eat a
couple of eggs every morning for
breakfast, not cooked in margin or
fried. Uh you want to consume as much as
72 ounces of red meat every month. I
know that sounds like a lot, but it's
just a quarter pounder a day. And you
want to supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients. And when you get to the the
vitamin E level, you want to have at
least 2,000 international units of
vitamin E and you want 500 micrograms of
selenium. And if you do that, even if
you already have Alzheimer's disease,
you can expect to have a significant
amount of return of memory. Great study
done by the University of California,
San Diego, and the Sulk Institute that
says by taking 2,000 international units
of vitamin E alone, even if you have
advanced Alzheimer's disease, you can
get a significant amount of of memory
return.